in Trump's chief strategist Eve Bannon
said there is no military option when it
comes to the growing nuclear threat from
North Korea in a rare interview Bannon
told The American Prospect quote until
somebody solves the part of the equation
that shows me that 10 million people in
Seoul don't die in the first 30 minutes
from conventional weapons I don't know
what you're talking about there is no
military solution here they got us
then Tracey's in Seoul where South
Korea's president spoke this morning
about the North Korean threat then good
morning good morning so Steve bannon's
comments are definitely at odds with
president Trump's threats to rain fire
and fury on North Korea but they're
probably more welcomed here in Seoul
South Korean president moon jae-in has
warned the United States not to start a
war here on the peninsula without his
country's consent today he said the u.s.
agreed to that and he unequivocally
stated that there will be no war on the
Korean Peninsula ever again
now we talked to president moons
national security adviser who said
despite being its main ally the u.s. is
not necessarily helping matters here on
the peninsula in this particular
instance do you think the United States
has made this situation better or worse
I think it was worse
we take crisis and conflict and
escalation on the Korean Peninsula damn
seriously he's a matter of life and
death for us and if there is any kind of
conflict if there is any kind of overt
conflict between Pyongyang and
Washington
ultimate collateral damage will be
placed on us and that damn it would be
catastrophe you would pay the price will
pay the price now the United States and
South Korea are moving forward with
planned military exercises that will
happen here next week the chairman of
the US Joint Chiefs of Staff says those
exercises are not up for negotiation
even though North Korea views them as
rehearsals for war gale
thank you very much Ben Tracy in Seoul